in today's game world number one Magnus  Carlsen battled against world number to  Levon Aronian it looked as though  crossin had the upper hand throughout  but aronian battle back and he was able  to hold the young phenom to a steady  draw well I just told myself I have no  right to looseness in the other match up  us number one player karunakar more  played this fantastic move Queen to c5  against his main American rival gotta  calm ski and with it was able to destroy  his opponent and take a commanding 20  lead into tomorrow's contest against  world number one Magnus Carlsen if I  play good moves I'll be fine that's I  mean there's nothing more to it be sure  to join us here at st. Louis chess club  com for exciting round 3 action of the  sink filled cup